[Musique]
des contraintes le projet a été donc de
créer des interfaces de fixation pour un
mât sur le véhicule ensuite une fixation
du radar sur le mât et ensuite de
s'occuper de la distribution pneumatique
du mât et la distribution électrique des
dessins conçus pour ensuite prendre
revis sur ces machines me nuiseries
chaudronnerie mécanique générale ou
peinture 18 salariés civils issus de
différents corps de métiers travaillent
dans cette ateliers de soutien aux
expérimentations leur rôle concevoir les
prototypes des futurs équipements de
l'armée de terre quand nous réalisons un
projet ce projet il est fabriqué soit à
partir de la matière bois ou ferraille
on peut également fabriquer des
maquettes en bois qui peuvent servir de
gabarit pour après être testé dans les
véhicules avant la confection à partir
de matière métal un réaménagement
nécessaire pour accueillir des armes en
constante évolution après trois ans
d'expérimentation les premiers véhicules
équipés du système anti drone seront
livrés aux forces fin 2023 dans une
version industrielle
[Musique]